we are here at san diego comic-con again
and this time we are with the cast of
teen wolf well two of the cast members
and the creator that's right
okay so jeff davis my first question is
for you um it's been five years since
the finale of the show can you tell me
how many years in universe it's been and
you know what's what's happening up at
beacon hills um i'm probably gonna get
this wrong but
because i did the timeline and i know
that
i i know what year the movie takes place
it's 2026 actually and right now in the
movie
uh scott mccall is actually older than
tyler posey yes i believe i'm 33. am i
allowed to say that yes scott mccall i
think is 33 years old and i'm only 12.
so
that's pretty cool right
emotionally and physically yes exactly
i have no comment for that
um so i just saw the teaser trailer and
it looked amazing i love the horror
vibes i love everything about it um what
can you tell us about that villain that
we're gonna see
in this movie you know who's the big bad
give us everything there's more than one
there's more than one the nogitsune has
returned don't say that that is the
voice you hear
but um there's gonna be some arrows shot
uh and fired towards uh scott mccall
that's right yeah yeah but he's gonna
you know he's gonna he's gonna man up
and and take it on
[Laughter]
i mean speaking of manning up
posey um tyler posey
it's been you you started this role when
you were like 18. exactly and it's been
a long journey what has it been like
playing scott as an adult and you know i
mean he's been in alpha this entire time
which is obviously quite a big time jump
what have you you know what's the
differences what have you learned in the
process yeah well what's really
interesting which we talked about on the
panel was that um being able to play
scott as a 30 year old man as opposed to
an 18 year old teen is a really um i
think really fun thing that i got to do
and also i
you see scott as this hero this werewolf
hero for the last uh
six years of the of the tv show now you
see scott as like an adult human and
scott's kind of taking a a little bit of
a break from the beacon hills world and
the hero world and and really tried to
kind of focus on what it is to be a
human adult which comes with a lot of
anxieties and stress and sometimes
depression and so i got to bring that to
scott which is something that we've
never really seen before he's had
anxiety he's been depressed before he's
he's been stressed out but in a
different sense you know no one's really
relying on him to save the world he's
kind of just trying to save himself as a
human you know and trying to live life
as a human rather than this supernatural
superhero um so i thought that was
really interesting because you know
throughout the years of teen wolf we
always i always try to
you know grow scott with with jeff's
writing and and have an arc for him and
this to me is the first time we've ever
seen scott in this aspect before and
that was just awesome to play
yeah i mean i can't wait to see it and
um tyler hecklin
it was revealed that you have a son you
have a child
how has it been eric has a child
well you've played a dad before i mean
you played your superman dad i mean
what has it been like being you know
derek the father
uh it's been a lot of fun i always say
i'm very grateful that on the show
jeff gave me such a great arc with derek
i feel like where he started in season
one and where his story ended was such a
complete journey for him as far as like
trying to figure out who he was and what
his purpose was and i feel like he found
that by the time we were done telling a
story on the show um so it was really
great to come back and to see him now
concerned with helping his son through
that same kind of journey so um for me
it was something really fun to come back
and do that was completely new with the
character uh it's different than the way
i play a father on the other show
which you know there's uh there's
different parenting styles i think clark
and derek have a lot of similarities but
also a lot of differences their
upbringings and their past experiences
are vastly different so um it was fun to
kind of be able to dip in and out of
both of those
i mean would you want to be raised by
derrick or by superman they both have
their perks
very fair a very fair answer
um jeff so we saw obviously at the end
of that teaser um alison is back and we
we knew crystal was going to be back in
the movie but i mean what can you tease
about her return it's not a cameo yeah
she's a big part of the movie
and um
and i think it's pretty significant
seeing her uh walk away from the uh the
burning wreck of a car
uh with arrows on her back so
um i don't want to say too much but she
has a lot of fun things to do in the
movie and
um
it was what was really fun about doing
this was one of the things we did was um
figuring out which characters haven't
been with each other in the show and i
realized i'd never put uh derek and the
coach in a scene together
so they have a scene together and it's
really fun it was fun so fun that was
great it's so good
okay well that's amazing i really can't
wait to see that now um just i mean so
obviously we all know that unfortunately
dylan o'brien cannot be a part of this
but i did see that his dad is style's
dad is still gonna be
on the show um what are you how are you
filling in that gap of styles not being
part of it he was such a pivotal part of
the group i mean yeah well
um
what we do is uh we we don't ignore it
but we reference it and i think you we
can't do the movie without paying
tribute to the character of styles
um so he comes up in uh more than one
situation and there's a big storyline
with lydia actually that the fans can
look forward to that has to do with
their relationship so i'm not gonna say
any more than that you can say more if
you want to
um so i mean you're coming back at comic
con you're getting to see the fans you
just did the panel
what is the aspect that you're most
excited to as far as um seeing you know
how the fans react to all of this
um i think it's just exciting because i
know
at least i think we're all aware that
the fans have been very
uh
how do you say loudly loud and
passionate about wanting more so uh it's
nice it feels like the right time it
feels like enough time has passed that
um for all of us in our lives we can
come back to it with kind of a fresh
take on it and for the characters
they've had enough time away to where we
get to
i think jeff kind of pitches to me when
we first talked about it it's like you
know give him the greatest hits but we
just have like a little something new
with all of those so i think people will
be excited to see everybody back but in
new places with new stories to tell uh
so i think i'm just excited that the
fans finally get what they've been
asking for for a minute
yeah the trick is to not not fall too
much into nostalgia it's to give them
something new as well and i mean when i
saw the shot for the first time in the
trailer of
derek and his son eli and they both
turned to camera i was like oh my god
that's good
they look great together
yeah vince vince mattis my playing my
son eli and he was great great young
actor and we're lucky to have him so
excited for people to love that little
[ __ ]
it's an inside joke between us he'll
understand
i mean i hope he does i'm fine with it
so uh just switching gears a little bit
jeff i want to ask about wolf pack
obviously you guys just announced that
sarah michelle gellar is going to be a
star and an ep what was it like getting
buffy you know to be a part of the wolf
pack well when someone mentioned her
name i was like can we get her is she
going to do a show like this she hasn't
done horror and tv in years since buffy
she did um a couple horror movies but in
tv it's it's different it's uh it's
every day
um
and when we met we had a zoom meeting
and my first my biggest uh thing was is
she nice is she a nice person to work
with cause i'm gonna point my career
around to want to work with [ __ ]
anymore
um and she's amazing she's such a pro
we're very lucky to have her and it was
really nice to have her here at comic
con hell yeah that was cool for us too
because like teen wolf has been so
inspired by buffy you know and in a lot
of aspects and the tone and everything
and so to have her here was
really special for us too so thank you
for bringing her yeah and we were on
stage with superman the teen wolf and
buffy the vampire slayer yeah pretty
kind of amazing pretty iconic and jeff
davis yeah goddamn right god damn right
i mean i have to ask since it involves
werewolves wolves in general are is
there any connection as far as um
universes go uh no good question so it's
they're totally separate and one of the
things i wanted to do with wolf pack was
make it its own new thing uh where the
rules were different the world was
different um it's got a different vibe
to it i'm not entirely sure i could do
uh another version of teen wolf and do
it as well as the first
yeah there's i mean the magic of the two
tylers and dylan and holland and crystal
that's uh that's lightning in a bottle i
mean that's tyler duo
that's a good group
so i i mean i just want to know
obviously this movie is we're getting a
revival
does the door does the doors leave
little do you leave the door a little
cracked open for future
teen wolf things or is it shut is this
that doesn't sound like a a question for
either of us
we'll see
um
always and forever
i love this show and i'm always down
sorry just scream in your ear no no no
we're worried about the guy with the put
the headphones on how you doing
yeah i'm always down always love this
show so please please write more
do more paramount we'll see plus if
everybody signs up for paramount plus
after watching this
they'll make me do more
i mean derek already has a kid you could
do the next generation they're all i
mean
i could send in universes have been made
unless
he's pretty damn good yeah he's great
love that guy i mean can you tell us
when we're gonna see this movie when
people are gonna be able to stream it i
know i'm asking the hard questions here
soon nice great answer will i be wearing
a scarf will i be wearing a flannel
that depends on what you like where
you're going to be
well that really depends
okay well i really want to know what was
it like you know as a cast getting back
together working on set together
especially i mean during covid all these
things i mean you've been apart what was
it like the greatest yeah uh i we always
there's a cliche of like you know you
you create a family when you do a show
and it's not always true but sometimes
you say that and i think for us you know
we really we always really meant that i
think everybody is just such a close
group i always say most of my best
friends are from this show and so to get
everybody back together and to show up
to work and be there at 5am and
racing against the sunrise and seeing
friends that you usually hang out with
and have dinner with all the time and
yeah covered in blood and a bunch of
other madness uh it's just it's special
especially after all these years to to
get everybody back together and do it
all over again
it's surprising to me too because i see
them on instagram and i'm like god they
really do like each other
they're hanging out going on vacations
yeah yeah
i don't like any of them
it doesn't sound like you're invited on
those vacations i'm not i'm too busy
it's always working he's always working
okay well i mean i need to know when you
guys are putting the makeup on when
you're putting you becoming the wolf do
you guys
what do you do to get into the zone of
you know of becoming the werewolf get
into the zone so our makeup guys are
awesome and they've been with us since
day one pretty much and so like they've
gotten a lot better at their craft also
you know which is why the the makeup
looks so good in this movie um and
they're the funnest most easygoing dudes
ever and it's
chris and eric chris and eric yeah and
and you know sitting in that makeup
trailer sitting down for two and a half
hours or plus uh could be kind of you
know annoying and grueling but with the
fact that these dudes are like the
coolest it's it makes it so much more
fun and it really helps kind of get us
into this sort of
i think what they think when you guys
put the fangs in there's jeff definitely
a feeling right yeah yeah yeah you like
when you have the prosthetic on it's fun
but you're kind of just talking and
chatting and you know you you look
different but when you put the fangs in
all of a sudden it's just like a
different yeah it's just like a
different energy all of a sudden and
you're in the muscles in your face and
it wants to growl do that they say it's
muscle memory i guess we've done it for
too many years it's easy to growl yeah
with things in for some reason also they
make it look really good i mean they do
such a good job with it that it's not
you know it's one of those things where
if you show up and you feel like you
look really funky and it's bad makeup
then you're kind of like
maybe a little self-conscious about it
but they do such a great job that you
know you kind of it it helps us believe
it a little bit as much as we can as
well so it's always it's always fun and
our post team is always really great at
making it look good so when you can
trust the people to take care of it
after you're done it's uh it's a little
bit easier to jump in and commit to that
okay well it sounds like once the fangs
are in you guys are blasting metallica
it's like you become a different person
yeah yeah pretty much yeah you're
actually not wrong about the metallica
part
it's pretty cool i mean you guys have
playlists like what is what is the music
that's playing on set playlist uh
ours varies a lot actually that's that's
something that was we started with uh
that i started with chris and then when
we would do it we would always like each
of us each time we knew we were gonna do
the wolf on the show that day like one
person would do like bring in a new band
we'd play like a bunch of albums and
then the next time the other person
would do it so the first one i think we
started with was black keys that was the
first one i brought in and i was like
let's do black keys today did black keys
and then i just spin it back and forth
chris has a great
taste in music it's bizarre and weird
and so i can never compete with it
tyler has blink 182 and continuous loop
inside of his head very true
well i know that had a strong influence
in your childhood and yes i mean i
understand that i
you you have the song that you like to
repeat you know very true so i you know
i want to know this cast has been so
tight-knit obviously with this movie i'm
wondering are we going to be introduced
to some new characters is there are
there new people joining into the
several new characters there's eli
derek's son played by vince mattis amy
workman plays hikari
um who's got a great storyline um
she's fantastic yeah yeah amy's awesome
she's such a good person and she's also
like the most badass of all of us like
she could she's actually like a trained
warrior yeah she also does cosplay and
she's really good she does she i'm
surprised she's not here no yes is she
here um but a couple other people as
well um
but we have we have a lot of main
characters to get through so not too
many people yeah there wasn't a lot of
room to introduce more yeah you know you
could always introduce more i'm sure the
fans will be very happy to hear that
advice no more new characters
[Laughter]
maxed out maxed out
okay so i mean we're at comic con we're
we're in the in the world of the fans
what are the things that you fan out
over and are you guys wasting any money
on the floor over here i wish i had time
yeah i usually like to walk the floor
and see the artist draw yeah um but i my
first comic con i came just as a fan
actually it was when they were start
just started doing the star wars
prequels
um
and it was one of the first panels i
think um
but uh i love comic con i love seeing
everything up and it's kind of amazing
here because
we were our first comic-con we were
basically slotted in because another tv
show cancelled and they were like we
have room my friend said do you want us
to get in here and then i was
sitting in a car uh with the chauffeur
and he asked me what we were what i'm
here working on and i basically said
that
and it was the giant teen wolf poster on
the building so it's quite a journey
yeah it's quite amazing yeah it's
awesome i
i'm fanning out over halo big time i was
a huge fan of the video game it's the
only video game i ever really played as
soon as that game stopped coming out i
just stopped playing video games
and it's such a good tv show and it's on
our same network you know it's paramount
plus also um but i haven't really i
don't think i've ever really explored
the floor ever it's scary here we go
we've been getting like a minute we've
been out there for like a minute one
time but yeah here the floor is it's uh
it's
not there's plenty for for signings yeah
it's a bit it's a bit of madness they
can't go out now so they would get
mobbed well i was gonna say like the
cosplay you could just you put a mask on
you put a helmet on you kind of explore
out there no one would know the
difference until you know until one of
them spots you when they're running
they're smart okay well i thought about
doing that like brian cranston did that
one year right i thought about doing
that yeah but he did that as he did
himself yeah yeah that was great i
thought about bringing my fangs
to this on this trip but i didn't bring
my fangs that's probably that probably
was for the best yeah i would have bit
you
probably 100 that's not going to stop
you but no
okay and on that note um
we want to thank you guys for chatting
with me i can't wait for the movie uh
yeah thank you thank you thank you very
much
you